my name is Alex power I've been here
since four am I do quality control and
education here at four-barrel coffee so
this is green coffee this is the state
that we received the coffee in what does
that plant look like it's a small shrub
kind of a scrawny looking shrub those
flowers will develop into a coffee berry
some people call it a cherry one single
cherry will produce this much coffee
that's it he's historically undervalued
from certain years we'll see like
producers in Guatemala two years ago
were hit really hard by coffee leaf rust
and as a result we had to pay more for
for what they were able to give us
because it became a very competitive
market and it's happened in El Salvador
as well what's the correlation between
the rust and climate change a Thursday
there seems to be correlation between
really warm and wet seasons
and the ability for fungus like rust to
propagate itself
certain parts of the world the climate
is changing in certain ways they're very
unpredictable and that amount of
unpredictability has really led to a lot
of problems with fungus and other pests
that sucks Alex it really does there's
really a whole art and science going on
back there roasting the coffee I really
have a newfound appreciation for the
producers the farmers at the coffee on
the ground over there because they're up
against so many different odds whether
it's unpredictable weather weather
patterns or you know rising costs and
stuff there's really so much that goes
into it that when we end up paying a lot
for quality coffee it makes sense this
is some terrible news because I just
learned that climate change is actually
threatening cocoa production which means
less chocolate for people who love it
like me and that changes everything